anrufe was ich bis jetzt als ein guter
autofahrer
aktive der ganzen linken dora zwischen
musik
willkommen in der forschung
das ist völlig erledigt sie möglichst
schnell hinter sich aber im ziel fest
vor augen und abschütteln paar stunden
manchmal wie sie nicht unter einem zeit
später vergab rasch zur fahrprüfung
[Musik]
drehtag und vorlegen
das ist mona und mittendrin
[Musik]
flughafen
für 20 jahre fahre aber mit einem
experten auf dem beifahrersitz des pkw
fahrprüfung sich krank
[Musik]
ok
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die gruppe das ist dass sich als links
lange genug druck
ich bin jetzt so ganz gute politik
da ist was man gebraucht
es ist schön
fazit fünfmal durch kite und da ist
trotz hilfe 20 jahren im studium und im
dank ihrer zentralen für die forschung
die streiks dorf
und dann können wir hier sehr verdient
die gruppierung
ich werde sicher brief schreibt wenn sie
zu fixieren sich unter den jungen als
problem
dieser bildband hat kaplan wiesenweg
fahrlehrer werde ich sicher ein wenig
oder viel schlimmer war jedoch nicht
geeignet falschen gründen beziehung und
falschen zügel noch so lang wie vor
schlechte autofahrer und ein vorurteil
aber zum glück sind sie fahrlehrer so
schwierige fälle wie mich gewöhnt erste
lektion der tat spielte schülerin
kontrollieren
du hast warum fahren sie einfach
geradeaus trees käme grundregeln für
fahrlehrer auf alles gefasst sie
frühzeitig kommando gegriffen nötig
dass gott mich jetzt muss da ja wenn wir
jetzt mal die zweite gang schalten nur
getan ist ihr siebter er wohl stets
frische völlig erledigt
rom ist ja klar fahren und bayern kenner
und wenn jetzt das nicht funktioniert
muss die studentin trainiert und mir
bitte hervor - sauber läuft
schön schön auf dem teppich bin
druckpunkt und legale und wie langsam
kohler sehr ruhig vermutlich hast du
jetzt publik schnell ja wohl noch mal
schnell kontrollblick und nicht und
jetzt ganz langsam fast geschafft im
märkischen mannschaft durch das
übernehme ich momentan nicht mehr wie
früher hilft mir rechts monat
[Musik]
im vierten versuch klappte zu erheben
oder titan green car seite bergsport
cleantech sie ich bin wieder bereit
dieses familienunternehmen oder mario
fernfahrt drücken denn ist ist kräftig
stiegen und zieht es jedes jahr
gewachsen
wirtschaft lfs tag steht die fahrlehrer
und lehrerinnen da glaub ich gehört aber
zu haben zieht durchschnittlich höhere
drehzahl von der meisterschaft so
bleiben müssen fehlen box im spiel
und sie sind sich an den sechs jahren
verbraucht
ich spaziere ich sage jetzt nichts dazu
sagen mit hoffentlich vor ort leben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gesellige teil für mich als vollmitglied
erste sturm mit immer vorschüler wir
warteten auf mich
[Musik]
fahrlehrer stand freeman direkten
schaffen wenn ich hunger freiheit hält
am morgen über den etat kubicki china
ich noch einmal autos zweitwichtigste
kreta
warum warum warum werken verarbeitet und
sich freute dass ich sicher ein punkt wo
ich die ist also vorsicht und ich wollte
hier und jetzt zu ruse forderte mit
blick auf verringerte speed bringen
die kombination und getrunken zu haben
[Musik]
der ingenieur ist ein dorf unter anderem
also sehr viel
[Musik]
viel interessanter 80 vom fahrer lucas
die macht sogar trecker treck bist du
das richtige also erst hinter skifahrer
und wenn einer form
er war es ruhig gelernt bin bahnhof
rangsdorf
[Musik]
wisi orbit rechtwinkelig rückwärts
papiere ins 14 jeder stelle ich würde
sagt intuitiv wird achtung seite rückt
uhr also gleichmäßig rollen und längsten
bis zum anschlag wenn fahrzeug gerade
räder im stehen gerade stellen
zurückfahren bis im parkfeld das seit
dieser seite
[Musik]
wie viel verstand es ist viel brot 12
die meisten 20 wie zwischen dem vfr
trikot
aber ehrlich sein dass die extreme
erfahrung zeige daher zu unseren ist
geld das man ganz einfach weitergefahren
das von extrem auch hier ist viel in der
favela verraten mit intelligenz zu tun
ist und greift das feeling
aber es ist ja so dass krieg oder als
gast war speziell da musst du voll im
griff war und ihr weniger so dass ich
bin der junge erlitt den inseln aber
leicht um sechs monate so dass nicht
mehr so viel gewinn vor steuern belaufen
so die meinung spielen
[Musik]
für mario g 12 stunden
ich nehme das sandwich mit brigitta
kuczynski ein ifo 2 fahrlehrerin vorteil
nation für die junge frau am steuer
ungeheuer ja nicht stehen wenn sie krieg
so etwa warum fraglich im raum schon 30
da hat er interne kritiker und solcher
markt gibt ich nur empfehlen zwei tage
haben sagte naber also er ist noch immer
der tat hilft ja ich bin
brigitta eine spezielle forscht und es
ist die letzte vor ihrer schülerin
samira die ränder muss man musste den
bus sofort jedes mal wenn du zu mir ist
cool soldat führer hat sich seit wieder
brühl fixie zu den hypo fremde tiere
danke
der bus ist wirklich extrem
das aufgebaute druck in der vorschule
die freue mich jetzt auch ein grafik
etat gibt es am ihrer not tipps wird
[Musik]
ok
zwischen darf der baum
nein
nicht dass für das teil da es ja das ist
exklusiv ihre manche mit der welt
praktikum machen mit dem keine vor
stunden geliebter natürlich diese
schicht hinter irgendwann eine sehr
harte sitze die meisten legen und mit
den codes machen wir da eine emotional
ist auch das ist immer da ist ihr
traumauto von eurer jugend und rechtes
bild 100000 franken schlitten mit dem
mineralstoff was nicht mittel paraplegie
wirklich für micky hirnschlag msv
einfluss eines die hand über die den
beruf viele kommunen ruf schulisch us
berater hat gezeigt
mario barths genau das muss es hier so
schnitts verrückt nehmen
das erste machen sie wählen manager
versucht oft im rahmen für die
gesellschaft sind uwe ruf und ist
zentrum stellen seite wert kostet die
fahrt im maserati übrigens gleich viel
wie eine normale lektion in frankreich
40 minuten
mir könnte forschen regiopole 850 etwa
chronischen krankheit immer mehr mühe
mit laufen
darum plant sie jetzt neu autofahrer die
zwölf die fahrstunde nieder so viel also
für mich ist das auto einfach das mittel
zum zweck eigentlich was ist es ist für
mich total lustig ist reaktionär und um
mit uns klebt und erzähler durch worten
erklären im maserati angriffe die
glauben mir das gar nicht zum lachen
ich fahre auf dem rücksitz mit wie
bittere lektion buchs
fingerspitzengefühl und erfahrung
anita fetz auto nur mit hand und fuß
bedarf
mit der linken hand stören sie mit der
rechte angeht sie gas und bremse
lemgo
vielleicht haben wir immer auf eine
verschwörung sind über nacht gekommen
ich hoffe dass sie noch in 10 10
sie heißt immer gas gebe es jetzt so
sieht ist er an genau wie vor
interessiert grad ab bei dem raum mit
dem maserati nett aber das gefühl kamen
der vollständigkeit von monatlich
möglich meinte schüler zum anderen das
ist leider schon reform lehrerin war
nächster watet durch mich zum ersten mal
bin ich unterwegs mit schülerin regler
busch wird und die ganze vor ort genau
vorbereitet vanessa ist zum glück york
wird die fahrerin
[Musik]
dadurch ziehen
[Gelächter]
immer konzentriert im lauf der bislang
wenig wird sein wirklich nur das
fahrlehrerin 6 mio
jedes jahr machen die die schweiz mehr
als 100 ressourcen glüht die praktische
prüfung ein drittel der folklore
[Musik]
von lars lagerbäck ihre mitte zu ihrer
forschung sind mühsam grunde sieht
brauchten viel kostet jetzt eher
unbewusst kurt jooss billigem autofahrer
ist wichtig dass wichtig für sicherheit
im verkehr
[Musik]
mono bestätigte die dfl verspannt ich
möchte ich vom hause weg längst fort von
-10 ist rasiert und ich bisher gespielt
er aber und das ist das auto war
ja was aber schon
doch so sicher besser wenn sich einen
ruf als sauber gemacht
der floh hat diese auto out of order
gekauft und umbaut fenster links ließen
wir haben einen stopp ins blickfeld und
dem klinikum selbst ein verlag mit
das ist schwierig noch etwas vor
klinkrad am kopf
ok ja doch immer auf der baustelle und
gewachst und so hätten die einfach ich
jetzt das was mit den tieren zu den
ritzen recht schick gefahren
aber langsam ist das sind stabil pack
ich darf erst denkt das ist so selten
nicht sehr schon graue aber gerade etwas
wir will aber irgendwie muss und den du
behauptest dass irgendwo was bedeutet
das für die das autofahren
darum hab selber vertreten es gibt mir
psychisch wieder filme ist das ganz
bitter
und ich kann o2 meldet lang müsse mit
der mv geschafft mit der winterthurer
mich gefragt wie das und denn das
bestanden dass die menschen wie im flow
wird beim bewusst gewichtige sonne vor
brühe wie kann sie wie sie bemängeln
darüber entscheidet wie selbstständiges
leben führen
[Musik]
bevor man überhaupt so briegert molde
wird machten rede forscher kräftig so
wie jetzt im dschungel
vorne links und den gerade wieder links
us-experten sie und das bedeutet
ernsthaft sorgen klare kommandos und
mitreden wenn es nicht nötig ist
[Musik]
das war jetzt ein
da machen
august dürfte siebte
mit einfach alles so wie du es 40
tobisch anderer stelle
dann müssten
spielleiter die experten dort häufig
fertig jetzt dafür einfach wieder rede
[Musik]
sagt wurde die show wirkt recht
entspanntes leben sehr gelassen
jetzt fehlen weil ich noch keine vhs ist
mehr oder weniger wolke heißt projekt
gestanden
ich will jetzt nachweisen warum java web
im werk sich nicht sicher ob es falsch
gemacht und dieses erreichte inneren
einschätzung ihres expertenaussage es
ist vieles gut sie aber noch so gut dass
ich mir sage du bist doch dabei geht es
um fragen aber ich wollte mein spiel
steckt wie und ich sagte zwanziger auf
wurde habe mir bei dieser gefundene ich
bbt sportarten wie das mache ich gar
nicht was ein baby spuren zum beispiel
wie schätzt du deine frau die laut wohne
und muss man scheinbar einfach sich so
unter ex zivi nach relativ schnell
wieder lernen und das gut aber es muss
ganz schnell ganz schlecht vor allem
fehle ihr mann so viel was wiederholung
also immer wieder holen und da will ich
gar nicht die verträge nicht versteht
als valerie ich habe mich für ihr
zweites gebäude ist für mich ist alles
schon gesehen haben uns ja vorher
gesehen und jena ja also ich hab doch
gesagt das ist ja auch c lizenz gebiet
habe ich noch jung ist die wer dennoch
in jugendliche 16 und so ich kann
englisch vereinbart dass ich habe einen
baum bevor er ist und hat mir gezeigt
was man mit lizenz gestellt zumal
natürlich sehr schön also wenn jüngere
scholes
also schaut wo wirklich warschau aber
will ich ganz ehrlich zu ihren job auch
unterschätzten aufwand ganz ehrlich ich
würde verantwortung übernehmen da da da
wo mich zwei spiele ausstehen aber durch
angelernt und vieles gesehen eine dritte
abonniert der lebemann oder höhepunkt
und gleichzeitig die schwierigste moment
im falle rot grün fix geht wird samir
und ihre lehrerin brigitta die
fahrlehrerin fluss mit brigitta hannover
sie sind dort kunde
mir ist
während der brief xl mit viel mehr
erfordert vom straßenverkehrsamt
[Musik]
im moment heißt samira geschafft oder
nicht
wir tun sicher
also doch verstanden was ist wenn ich
schlafe zeit trug die fahrschule wartet
die beiden chefs der experte
ja das ist als experte fazit ist der
herr manfred herr manfred
bundesregierung eine interessante frage
sie will erstreckt sich rum bin mir mit
diesen kameras dbx sie sind häufig
bestanden ziel erreicht und das social
network sondern messi
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich schon gefreut kommentar zu
fahrschule und unterwegs in fracks und
mona mittendrin und andere doch seien
die gewinner am einfachsten kanal
abonnieren dann könnt ihr mal und ist